for these afghans trying to build new
lives in britain cricket is proving a
common language up to 200 refugees are
awaiting permanent resettlement in and
around newport pagnel in buckinghamshire
the town cricket club a diversion from
uncertainty for people like nazir a
former translator for the royal marines
on the front line in helmand who fled
threats from the taliban earlier this
month it is very difficult because
your children they they are going to
school and once you
you get any threat or intimidation later
from insurgents back in afghanistan and
you change your location so you have to
change your children's school as well
so from the beginning they start their
classes they start their lessons it is
very difficult
while these families wait to hear where
they'll finally be housed the local
community has stepped forward
this is just a small amount of the
donations that we've received over the
past i mean this is a week less than a
week even
and it gives you a baptist pastor steve
wood has helped coordinate the support
and this is what we've been overwhelmed
quite literally overwhelmed by that by
that by the compassion of a community
that simply sees people in need and
wants to help them
and uh are there any dissenting voices
maybe one or two but they are soon
drowned out
by just the yeah this overwhelming
response
and desire to see people treated as
people
goodwill will only go so far local
authorities already facing chronic
housing shortages will ultimately have
to find people homes
the government says it wants to offer a
warm welcome to up to 20 000 afghan
refugees offering accommodation and help
into employment and education and while
communities like this are doing what
they can the agencies will have to turn
that sentiment into reality so they face
major practical challenges we don't know
exactly
who's coming over what their needs are
how much support they will need uh you
know
how much housing we will have to
go into the market and either acquire or
rent and until we know those things we
we actually don't know the financial
implications so i'm reassured that
government has said they will fund this
the government's plans for afghan
refugees are based on the syrian
resettlement program which left some
facing poor accommodation and regular
moves offering refuges one thing
providing a home
quite another
paul kelso sky news in newport pagnel